i i couldn't imagine you know you know
your your father
late father jason miller was a pulitzer
prize winner he
he was the priest everybody knows the
priest and the exorcist which was like
unbelievable performance in that he was
a great actor and of course your
father's donald sutherland so
it's like there's no [ __ ] way that
it's easy
because your fathers are probably both
out they're all doing their things
they're having careers and like being a
kid it's got to affect you as a kid
there's no doubt
uh not having him around all the time
and so i mean but growing up
a sutherland growing up uh uh you know i
guess like a miller at the time
at the time i mean how how difficult was
that and is it something that
you know because i have stuff that
happened from charlotte and you let
things go i'm an adult
you know my father i've talked about
he's never capable of saying i love you
i'm proud of you good job i've never
heard those words even still
even still you don't hear those words
you don't hear them that's just not
but i've learned that that's just to you
know he can't do that that's not who he
is
and i forgive him i love him but as a
kid
not hearing you're really good or
you're smart i love you those are
[ __ ] difficult things not to hear
so i'm just wondering did you guys hear
that stuff
was that the constant or is it something
you always were chasing or
was it hard growing up i had a great
childhood i mean i honestly have a
pretty awesome life
actually um you know i didn't grow up
with my dad i grew up with my mom right
uh a great theater actor uh
every night after school have to go to
the theater do our homework
uh wait till the play performance was
over and then we'd all go home
so i was around the theater a great deal
that's where i started
that's where we ended um
you know so and as a kid you just what
you get is what you know
so i didn't have any trauma or drama or
you know
and yeah my dad was was
working and and i think
probably one of the most prolific
important careers in
the english language you know and i'm
his son and i'm
hugely proud of him uh did we spend a
lot of time together no
um do i understand it absolutely
yeah um and we tried to make up for it
as years went by you know did that work
out
yeah yeah i mean it's our thing is our
thing and it's it is what it is
so you know but i'm hugely proud of him
i'm i
think he's an incredibly smart sometimes
very very funny guy
um and he's a brilliant brilliant actor
and was really important
uh i think to cinema and so
it's what it is it also allowed me at a
very early age to go i'm going to do
what i want
you know because everybody else did so i
found that to be really helpful
yeah i always felt like there was a
little competition with my dad and i
like there was always like
you know i was an actor and he's working
his ass off and making
you know go to school and study and run
a plan i was like oh you're making all
this money being an actor that's not
[ __ ] work
i mean obviously he was an actor so you
were both doing the same thing but did
you ever feel like there was a
competition
no no no it was i mean
it was interesting for me things timing
timing worked out my father had moved to
france
and decided to take a few years off he
has three
younger sons uh with a different
mother or wife and uh so he took
you know a sabbatical for really almost
a decade
and that was right when we started doing
lost voice in our
and my film so and i've asked him he
didn't do it on purpose but he left a
window open for me that i thought was
you know pretty cool and
and so yeah so i i never felt that i i
just uh
i'm sure you've had your moments no i
mean i
i honestly i'm thrilled when he's happy
with the stuff that he's done
uh and i'm thrilled when things are
going really well for him
uh and equally i'm grateful for the
opportunities i've had
and he commends you you if is he'll call
you after something i love that yeah
yeah and you do the same yeah yeah
absolutely wow
how did it affect or did it affect how
you raised your kids
you growing up with an absent father did
it have a change
well it's not so much
no because i mean i worked and uh i made
a point of
of kind of being in the same town
as my daughter i think the biggest
change for me
was i got divorced
uh from my daughter's mother uh when my
daughter was quite young
and i think i made a point of handling
the divorce in a certain way
that i didn't that i didn't think either
of my parents
and did that very well uh so i
i made a point of really trying to do
that
well and camilla and i are still really
close friends
uh to this day we still have
thanksgiving and christmases together
uh so i think we've done that about as
well as as you can
it's not something i'm recommending for
anybody out there
uh try and avoid divorce right and uh
you know i'm i love camellia and always
will i mean it's why we got married
uh and we were lucky enough to be able
to kind of take care of each other
um financially and in other ways which
is generally what makes people
kind of go crazy it makes it easier on
the kid though when you're friends
it's certainly you know it certainly
does and and the you know
the one person in the group that didn't
get to make any of these choices is the
poor child
so yeah yeah and
and she's extraordinary and michelle and
uh
so you yeah so that was probably you
know in looking back at
as a parent looking back on my life
if there was one kind of moment that i
tried to do differently
it would be divorce